[Music]
[Applause]
so for many what makes a nation seems
obvious its history and its people but
does that mean Native Americans and
Australians should control their lands
should Ireland belong to the Irish his
nation had an accident of previous
tribal battles over borders and a means
of holding on to the spoils or is it a
shared culture and community that is for
the benefit of all so first on my left
here we have a left second Elif is a
Kurdish rights activist she comes to the
festival today shortly after her visit
to reserva in northern Syria next we
have David Blunkett former Home
Secretary David was one of the most
respected members of Tony Blair's
cabinet on top of the home secretary
position Branca also served as education
and employment secretary and Work and
Pensions secretary and in 2015 he was
awarded a peerage and became Balan
blanket and then last but not least we
have Eric Kaufman Eric is a Canadian
professor of politics at Birkbeck he's a
specialist in nationalism and demography
and if that's not enough he is also the
author of several books including white
shift populism immigration and the
future of white majorities now you know
our panel let's hear their thoughts on
our borders simply accidents of history
Alif won't you kick us off one thing
that I think people everyone can agree
on is the fact that borders and nations
are were and are a political project so
therefore it was built and created by
people or systems or ideas of their
particular ideas so you know when we
talk about you know the idea of borders
and nations I like that this top that
this title also has the idea of history
in him and I think why that's relevant
is that the idea of borders and nations
especially you know on the scale of the
history of history of humanity but also
even civilization are very new
a very new phenomenons the nation state
and therefore borders are very new and I
think also one of the things we can
comfortably say is they never have
really brought anyone any any nation for
that matter any long-term or lasting
peace for full liberation you must
overcome and essentially bring down all
forms of oppression and enslavement and
therefore this includes borders and the
nation-state as well now hopefully we'll
hunt get and get a chance to speak about
nations and be able to talk about the
difference between nations in the
nation-state in our discussion but when
I talk about borders I I mean the
nation-states thank you very much for
setting out those initial thoughts so
David the same question to you our
borders simply accidents of history well
I think those of us who are British by
heritage have got to be very careful how
we address this because our Imperial
history has been a disaster in terms of
drawing other people's borders in South
Asia and Iraq and across the world so
it's with some temerity that I would say
that the there are different borders
that people need to belong they have a
sense of needing an identity that they
can share with other people and it might
be language and it might be a language
and faith and it might be culture and it
might be drawing down on sometimes
erroneously their history but it's it's
about people as gregarious human beings
wanting to be together and when when
they start the process of expanding from
a close-knit community identity then you
get into the Imperial either military or
economic imperialism where other
people's borders are encroached on and
their way of life is infringed so I
would say that for many people in the
world their borders are a few miles from
where they live and work still in my
community that I grew up in people still
are not if you like citizens of the
world they may fly on holiday
but it's not common whereas but many
people here at hey it would be and we
would see the world in a different from
a different perspective so I think we
come at it in that guise here in Britain
of course we've we've had the Danes and
the Vikings we've had the Normans we've
had people coming in with its Huguenots
or people fleeing from persecution
across the world the Windrush
interesting about the wind rush because
when they came 70 years ago they saw
Britain as the motherland so the borders
that they were seeing were borders based
on geography they were based on what
they'd been ain't what inculcation had
taken place in terms of a a combined
history I don't think people would see
that now they didn't get a great great
welcome from the motherland as we all
know I've tried and perhaps we come back
to this to say that developing common
values for citizenship and recognizing
that wherever anyone came from is the
real challenge for the future thank you
very much David okay last but not least
Eric your thought to this question of
borders simply being an accident of
history right so the question is our
borders accident of history and I think
the truth is in part they are I mean as
Charles Tilly the political historian
once said national borders are the
high-water point of dynastic
expansionism and we know that
post-colonial of nation-states a lot of
their borders are straight lines which
were drawn by the colonial power so yes
borders are in some degree an accident
of history but at the same time we also
know that collective will has also
shaped the location of national borders
if we go back to ancient Israel and if
you look in the Old Testament talking
about the borders of Israel from Dan to
Beersheba now there of course there many
concepts of the Promised Land in the
Bible that's only one of them I don't
pretend it's the only one but this is to
say that groups were already talking
about some kind of territorial reference
points even back in ancient times and
certainly as we come through history
there are many instances if you think of
the poles more recently South Sudan or
or East Timor where it's not just great
power deal stitching up
where the borders are even though that's
important but it's also some sort of a
national self-determination claims so I
just want to suggest that it's both
top-down statecraft but also bottom-up
collective will that that is important I
would also say that once the national
boundaries crystallized in the modern
nation-state and this is taught to the
population through the media mass
education mass literacy you get a large
scale attachment to national borders in
the population and once that occurs
borders actually become real for a lot
of people national identities for many
people are very important and as Michael
Walzer the political theorist says you
cannot have national you can't have
communities without boundaries so I'm
afraid that boundaries are part of what
it means to be a nation that's where the
common rights and duties that we owe to
each other the willingness to share
wealth to engage in the demos where that
where that ends and that is a necessary
part I would argue of of nation and
national attachments last thing I'm
going to say really which concerns
migration because the book my book is
really about the rise of populism
migration is central to that story and
communal boundaries as expressed in
national borders are very central to not
just protection against invading armies
but also to the migration question we
have to have migration but nations do
have an interest in regulating migration
levels that could be controversial or
maybe not and I think we have to accept
that that is part of what's a writ
emerged because of these national
attachments that people have formed they
are therefore interested in this
question of migration and one of the
reasons we are getting right-wing
populism is because of a reaction or
response to migration we can get into
that in more detail okay fabulous thank
you very much for those opening pictures
allophonic come to you first again with
our first theme our borders more trouble
than they're worth
which I think inherently has within it
an idea of the value of value of
boulders which maybe you want to call
into question what do you think about
that opening thing I mean the short
answer is yes but you know when we talk
about you know I think we really get
into
we get into ideological territory when
we start when we start equating national
identity or belonging with boundaries
and borders you know we we've seen and
unfortunately we don't have much time to
go into you know 5000 years of the
history of civilization but you know one
of the things that is important is that
you know the idea of boundaries you know
say the Middle East
I mean Ovie I'm from I'm from London so
I know the UK very well as well but I
also know about the geopolitics of the
Middle East and one of the things so
when I was in northern Syria actually
not that recently it was last April well
I suppose that's kind of recent one of
the things that you see is exactly in
one place that there's Kurds Arabs
Assyrians turkmens see reacts you know
so many different kind so many different
people who live in one place and every
single one of those people also
historically come from that place so
where do you draw the boundaries and
where do you draw the borders without
without without then that those borders
in yet again creating the oppression or
the denial of a particular people the
podcast talks debates courses and
articles visit the Institute's of art
and ideas click the link on screen now
to IE
TV